it's the defining image of bloody sunday
the priest with the bloodstained
handkerchief seeking help for one of the
wounded seventeen-year-old jackie duddy
was the first to die his sister kay
wants the soldier who killed him to
admit it
please put your hands up and say he did
it
so as we can
lay our way brother to rest my way
brothers jackie dolly's been buried for
50 years but as up to this moment in
time it hasn't been laid to rest
because hiking nearly some day rest we
are just distilled
without justice for what happened that
awful day
13 people were shot dead when members of
the parachute regiment opened fire in
londonderry only one soldier was ever
charged but the case collapsed
the idea that unarmed people marching
for their own civil rights for justice
and for democracy
were gunned down on their own streets by
special forces uh regiment i mean it is
it is beyond belief that that happened
it's beyond belief that that was allowed
to happen that it was laid about that it
was covered up for decades after decades
the dead were exonerated by a public
inquiry but the lack of justice and the
government's plan to halt historical
prosecutions here haunt this community i
mean imagine if this happened in london
or liverpool or manchester or birmingham
so this is why bloody sunday has had
this this long tail if you like that has
impacted not just on the families and on
on the city but on on the the troubles
on how that developed i mean bloody
sunday was absolutely the cataclysmic
turning point that sent northern ireland
tumbling into into decades of violence
to mark the 50th anniversary this city
will fall silent at the precise moment
the first shot rang out on bloody sunday
by the end of that day 108 live rounds
had been fired
and 13 innocent people were dead
five decades may have passed but those
who did not return from the civil rights
march are not forgotten here how often
do you think about jackie every day of
my life
every day of my life seemed to do the
rest of our family
that awful day we didn't just lose a
brother we lost a generation
etched on the walls and on their hearts
the memories keep them going in their
quest for justice
david blevins sky news in derry